hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today is Thursday it's another
destiny recap except this time the dev
stream was basically filled with nothing
at the moment it there wasn't too much
stuff that was worthy of mentioning but
there are still a few things that I do
want to talk about so let's get ready
so first up on the list Xbox one X
players are going to be receiving a free
graphics update to make for honor look
even better in 4k resolution I do
believe I don't have an xbox one X
although I do have an Xbox one so if you
do have that you'll get a free update to
make it look better that's not really
too big but this weekend though there is
going to be a new like double xp here
I'm not double xp double like loot type
fest it's called the extra loot fest and
it reads saying as December brings out
the dark and cold nights receive more
loot for those who choose to fight it's
going to be a extra loot so if you're
into that for honor fashion or if you
just want to get that one specific
looking gear or whatever you might want
you can go get the double loot this does
not include steal sadly but once again
its loot so it's something game updates
though the dev team is working and
playing and testing on the dedicated
servers so hopefully that will be going
well they did say that it's working
pretty well also they're gonna be trying
to open up a beta test server or
whatever we had the PTR the pts for us
for the PC players they're gonna try to
get that out to everybody who knows yet
but I'll keep you all updated on that
and then the last two things they talked
about is that there's going to be a few
bugs that they're changing or they're
going to be fixing in the rank 2
Dominion playlist that regards to
matchmaking and then the devs are also
going to decide are deciding on whether
they make a new front or a new tab that
has specifically ranked game modes in it
oh and I almost forgot we have a weekly
content and the new weekly content is
going to be a new effect called demonic
so I'll show that video real quick for
you guys right now
[Music]
[Music]
so that was the video like I said the
demonic thing it's not too bad it's use
its casual effect it's nothing that
great it's nothing too bad so it's
whatever you want if you want to buy
that go for it it's good it should be up
by the time you log on and that's about
it like I said the video the stream
wasn't too incredible but I did want to
mention one really quick thing I put out
a community post yesterday or a couple
days ago I believe and I mentioned in it
if you didn't already see it I will
gladly show it to or I will gladly tell
you again basically I'm gonna start
doing weekly streams I talked like three
months ago saying I was gonna start
streaming more often because I did like
it I loved interacting with all of you
guys in the chat but since school
started and a lot of other bullshit's
been going around in my life it's been
kind of lowering the chances of me being
able to stream
so roughly starting this weekend so in a
couple days I should be streaming weekly
hopefully weekly but definitely this
weekend I'm gonna be streaming some of
the extra loot just because if you guys
do want to stop by that'd be greatly
appreciated if you also since I'm using
these community posts more often I'm
gonna be showing I'm gonna be telling
everyone an updated time whether that be
Friday Saturday or Sunday wherever it
happens to be whatever time I decide to
stream I'll put it on the community tab
for all of you guys to be caught up in
so definitely make sure to hit that Bell
next to that subscribe button just so
that you guys can get in on the loop
just so you don't miss a stream of mine
anyway with that out of the way I hope
you guys did enjoy if you did please
sure to leave a like subscribe if you're
new to form more for honor content I
covered the news the leaks the
discussions the Deaf stream recaps of
for honor and on top of that might as
well hit the bell right next to it so
once again you can get the notifications
of when I stream and all that good stuff
and when new videos pop up so you could
be part of the notification squad too
news videos are popping up on the screen
if you guys do want to check those out
and get caught up on the day on the
weekly news a for honor and with that
guys hope you have a great rest of your
day and peace out